هل اصبح المحتوى المكتوب على هامش
الانترنت مقابل التوجه العالمي نحو مزيد
من استهلاك الفيديو نحو اثنين وتسعين في
المئه من مستخدمي الانترنت في جميع انحاء
العالم يشاهدون مقاطع الفيديو الرقميه كل
اسبوع بما فيها المقاطع الموسيقيه
والبرامج التعليميه ومقاطع الالعاب
والمؤثرين والمشاهير
تقرير حاله الانترنت لعام 2023 الذي نشرته
شركه اوبرلو يفيد ان استهلاك الفيديو عبر
الانترنت شهد ارتفاعا ملحوظا ليصل الى
سبعه عشره ساعه في الاسبوع بحسب التقرير
يقضي المستخدم شهريا نحو 23 ساعه و 28
دقيقه في الشهر على تيك توك يليه مباشره
يوتيوب بثلاث وعشرين ساعه وتسع دقائق وهما
منصتان مختصتان بمقاطع الفيديو
وتحل خدمه في الفيسبوك في المرتبه الثالثه
بتسعه عشره ساعه وثلاث واربعين دقيقه
الامر لا يقتصر على زياده استهلاك مقاطع
الفيديو المحمله بل ان مقاطع الفيديو
المباشره على الانترنت نمت مشاهداتها
بمقدار 15 ضعفا في فتره خمس سنوات من 201
الى 2022 وذلك وفقا لدراسه اجرتها شركه
سيسكو لتكنولوجيا الاتصالات ويبدو ان
منصات التكنولوجيا المختلفه
تتعمد وضع العراقيل امام المحتوى المكتوب
فيسبوك مثلا يعتبر ان المحتوى الذي يتطلب
جهدا اقل للاستهلاك والفهم
يتمتع بمعدلات مشاركه اعلى وذلك بمبرر ان
طول مده قراءه الشخص يزيد صعوبه الاستيعاب
والفهم فيما تفضل خوارزميه تويتر المحتوى
الغني بالعناصر البصريه اكثر من النص
المجرد
ويفضل مستخدم جوجل وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي ومقاطع الفيديو في الاكتشاف
والبحث وفقا لمسؤولين في جوجل نفسه تحديات
يرى المدافعون عن المحتوى المكتوب انها
قد تحد من تطوير واسراء الانتاج الفكري
وتعزيز حضور اللغه في شبكه الانترنت